the rate that new technology is adopted
is accelerating
in america the use of the internet was
adopted six times faster than
electricity had been when it became
available a century earlier
but greater innovation can bring greater
risks which require more control
many aspects of our lives are very
heavily regulated things like food
medicines cars
aviation
these are all things where if something
goes wrong it can be really bad lots of
people can die
too many rules can stifle creativity
while too few can lead to tragedy
there's a very common perception that
regulation and innovation are sort of
opposed to each other if you have more
of one then you'll get less of the other
so how can we maximize the benefits of
innovation while also reducing its risk
technology has delivered longer safer
and more interesting lives
but innovation is always a journey into
the unknown
when you have a new technology it's
going to have unexpected consequences
it's going to be used in unanticipated
ways some of those will be good some of
them could be harmful so this is where
regulators step in
most key technologies are heavily
regulated
cars aviation healthcare
finance
the difficulty is that technology moves
quickly regulators move slowly
so finding the right way to regulate a
technology is always very difficult it's
a sort of balancing act
the challenge of balancing innovation
and risk is seen in the tantalizing
progress of one particular technology
autonomous cars
i think it's a very interesting
technology that you know potentially
could make a big difference in the
future the trouble is it doesn't quite
work yet
several tech companies are racing to
develop autonomous vehicles
google's sister company waymo is one of
the leaders
it runs a fleet of fully driverless cars
already out on public roads
here in october 2020 we launched our
first commercial product in arizona so
if you were to fly into chandler arizona
and download the waymo app you could hop
into a fully autonomous car
you get into the car buckle up
hit a button of where you want to go and
you're on the road
our weight low driver never gets tired
never gets distracted is never grumpy
nearly 40 000 people die and millions
are injured every year on america's
roads
so putting driverless cars on public
highways could present a huge risk
can we build a vehicle that can drive in
ordinary traffic with other road users
with cyclists with pedestrians with
other cars and there are humans that
can't do that
the challenge is getting these vehicles
to work not in a controlled environment
in the everyday world which is a complex
and unpredictable place
waymo chose chandler as its test site
because arizona state regulations gave
it greater freedom to experiment
arizona has made an intentional decision
to become the center of innovation for
autonomous vehicles
we helped to pass and worked hand in
hand with policy makers and other
stakeholders to really get the
legislation passed
and so the current regulatory atmosphere
has been one that we've been able to
help shape and help inform
uber
another company racing to develop
autonomous vehicles
began testing in nearby tempe to take
advantage of arizona's regulatory regime
but the regulations were thrust into the
spotlight one sunday night in march
2018.
seriously hurting a crash with a
self-driving uber elaine herzberg was
killed as she crossed a road in tempe by
a test car belonging to uber
a safety driver was on board at the time
but failed to prevent the collision
the vision system couldn't figure out
what was happening didn't put on the
brakes and hit her
and some people have said that you know
had there been a stricter regulatory
regime around these vehicles then this
accident wouldn't have happened
following the accident arizona
immediately suspended any further
testing of uber's autonomous vehicles
waymo continued to operate in chandler
and insists that its technology is safe
we've done 20 million miles of testing
on public roads and just recently we
released a safety paper for the public
for academics and policy makers to
really look at our safety outcomes we
looked at six million of our autonomous
smiles and we found that we had only
very minor collisions in those six
million miles of driving
the proof is in the numbers
we are a very safe autonomous vehicle
service
for self-driving cars and their
regulators the biggest hurdle may not be
safety but public opinion
the evidence so far is that autonomous
cars are very safe drivers so about 40
000 people die on the roads every year
in america for example if you make an
autonomous car a thousand times safer
you're still going to have 40 people
being killed by autonomous vehicles
every year everyone is going to be a
newspaper headline you know person
killed by robot car
while too little regulation can be risky
too much can be bad for business
and those in the know claim this is the
case with another emerging technology in
america
drones
two big dangers with drones one is
they'll fall on your head and kill you
the other is they'll crash into some
other flying vehicle and make that crash
and so clearly this is not something
where you can just have a free-for-all
let people do whatever they like you've
got to have rules
since 1958
the body that sets those rules in
america has been the federal aviation
administration
aviation for 100 years has involved
carrying people somewhere in the air
on a giant metal structure
with thousands of gallons of fuel
strapped underneath
along came drones i think it's fair to
say the regulators didn't know what to
do with that because their entire
history and structure has been focused
on
protecting people on board an aircraft
by creating very high standards both for
the pilot as well as for the aircraft
the faa's reaction was to make flying
drones commercially very hard indeed
initially if you wanted to fly a drone
in order to take pictures of a property
that was being sold or survey a building
site you couldn't do it unless you had a
pilot's license
many people felt that this rule was sort
of silly it was imposing the rules for
the old technology on the new technology
the faa updated its regulations in 2016
but some argue that the rules are still
lagging behind and stopping drones from
fulfilling their full potential
the next frontier for drones and and
their regulation really is what's called
beyond visual line of sight
and this would enable drones to fly
unlimited distance autonomously
you can't gain much value out of
delivering a package only a couple
thousand feet you could just walk it
over there or drive it if you're going
to do package delivery with the drone
you're going to want to fly a few miles
u.s drone company wing is already doing
this but not at its base in california
more than seven thousand miles away in
logan australia
wing went to australia for a number of
reasons
the regulator in australia has very high
safety standards and we knew that we
would be able to work with them to
ensure that our operations were reviewed
carefully and they would be safe
and now we're doing thousands of
deliveries a week to customers
on line of sight is really necessary for
operations to scale over time
some claim the faa has driven these
innovations overseas
behind the scenes there's tremendous
frustration that the fa is not moving
fast enough other countries are ahead
for something as serious and obviously
regulated as aviation where you you just
know that rules are coming
it's very difficult to convince
investors to put their money in to
something when literally the government
is telling you
this is not currently permitted and we
don't know when we're going to have a
set of rules
letting large numbers of drones loose in
already crowded airspace is definitely a
safety challenge
the technology exists today to allow us
and others to operate beyond line of
sight and the regulatory environment
will have to adapt to allow that to
happen
what we have in the united states so far
is basically no risk tolerance we need
to figure out ways to promote their
integration into society rather than
dwelling in these overly conservative
traditional
safety frameworks that don't really
apply to these types of risks
if too much regulation can smother
innovation and too little can be
dangerous is there a middle ground
there are times when regulation and
innovation go hand in hand so they're
not always enemies what it's all about
is having the right kind of regulation
having smart regulation and a really
interesting example of that is what
we've seen recently in financial
services with so-called sandbox
regulation
the british financial technology sector
was an early adopter of sandbox
a sandbox is a place where
kids can play with buckets and spades
and sand and mud and they can make a
mess and it's fine to make a mess in the
sandpole you wouldn't let them do that
on the living room floor but a sandbox
is a controlled closed environment where
making a mess is allowed
keeping innovation in a controlled
environment is sensible in the
fast-moving financial sector
if a bank fails or something goes wrong
lots of people lose lots of money and so
the sandbox lets you have the best of
both worlds it means that there's close
regulatory supervision but there's also
lots and lots of scope for innovation
the sandbox approach helped london
become a world leader in financial
technology a sector worth more than six
billion pounds to the uk economy
and it's now being adopted for another
emerging technology that's on the move
electric passenger flight known as evie
toll
the civil aviation authority regulates
britain's airspace
we see significant potential for ev tall
in the near term in terms of adapting
existing helicopter markets but also in
the long term it could potentially play
a role in connecting up different parts
of the country evital aircraft are
similar to drones powered by motors that
run on batteries but big enough to carry
passengers
vertical aerospace in bristol has
already flown a prototype
we're looking at decarbonisation of
aerospace which has historically been a
very polluting environment and moving
more towards battery power taking energy
from renewable sources
vertical aerospace is part of a
consortium of companies in a regulatory
sandbox working with the civil aviation
authority
collaboration is really important so
that we can ensure that we have an
ecosystem ready to accept an aircraft
when it actually goes into full-scale
production we don't have to choose
between innovation and regulation if we
engage with someone at an early design
stage or a conceptual stage then what
we're helping them to do is build a
product that can actually be regulated
rather than coming in at the end and
effectively kicking it into touch
autonomous vehicles drones evital
aircraft
three new technologies with the
potential to deliver great benefits
but also real dangers
regulation needs to be used to manage
the risks while also maximizing
potential rewards it's tempting to see
regulation and innovation as a sort of
seesaw when one of them goes up the
other one goes down but actually the
reality is more complex than that and
there are ways that you can have safe
sensible regulations and still have lots
of innovation
i'm tom standage deputy editor of the
economist and editor of the world ahead
to read more of our future gazing
coverage click on the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
you